Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Dr. Bil'in Jalal, who's a researcher
at Harvard University and visiting researcher
at Cambridge University, one of the world's
leading experts, on sleep paralysis.
It's really great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Oh, I'm glad to be here, David.
Speaker 1: So sleep, sleep is such an interesting
field because it seems to me it's difficult
to study it without affecting one's sleep
in the sense that many of the settings in
which sleep is studied, like sleep labs, for
example, are very unnatural situations to
do something that most of us do every day,
which is sleep asleep while being observed,
sleep with electrodes on etc.
It seems that it's difficult to get great
data for that reason.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Is that true?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
I mean, you know, bringing somebody into a
sleep lab and hooking them up with these electrodes
and things like that and having them sleep
in a sleep lab is obviously not, as, you know,
useful as as the home environment where you
naturally sleep and things like that.
So I agree it is difficult, but nonetheless,
it's it's doable.
But I agree, you know, we don't have that.
So it's a bit of a tricky thing in that way.
Speaker 1: Let's maybe start and talk a little
bit about sleep paralysis now.
To some degree, in certain phases of sleep,
we are paralyzed in the sense that we might
be dreaming of taking some physical action
and you aren't taking that physical action
in the real world.
You might be punching someone in a dream,
but your body is not going out and punching
into the air.
And that's a good thing when it happens in
the in the correct times.
Is that right?
Speaker 4: That's right, David.
So each night we cycle through these 90 90
minute cycles of sleep.
And if you sleep eight hours, I hope you do,
then you have like maybe four of these blocks.
And during one of these stages, you go through
something called REM sleep, and during REM
sleep, you have these bizarre and lifelike
crisp dreams.
You know, the ones where you see yourself
on the moon, wrestling with an alligator and
then having tea with the Queen, everything
is just messed up, you know?
So during these dreams, you certainly don't
want to act these dreams out and hurt your
sleeping partner.
So your brain essentially the lower part of
the brain, paralyzes your entire body.
And so, yeah, you have this paralysis each
night.
You know that that you you go through pretty
much now
Speaker 1: when we talk about sleep paralysis
as a as a phenomena and condition, what we're
really talking about is outside of REM sleep,
the body remaining paralyzed
Speaker 4: while sleep paralysis is basically
this like.
So you are in this paralysis state during
this REM stage of sleep and then suddenly
parts of the brain that has to do with sort
of sort of wakefulness centers of the brain
cortical regions, they become prematurely
activated.
So you start waking up in a way even though
you're still paralyzed in REM.
So it's at this synchrony to the architecture
of REM, whereby your brain suddenly switches
so it's awake and sleeping at the same, you
know, in the same way at the same time.
So you have this clash of wakefulness and
REM paralysis occurring at the same time.
So that what what sleep paralysis
Speaker 1: is, how common is that?
Speaker 4: You know, about 20 percent of the
population have experienced sleep paralysis
at least one time.
But then you have maybe one or two percent
that have it more chronically.
So they will have sleep paralysis, you know,
two or three times a day or a week or, you
know, five or six times a month.
So it is really but at least one in at least
20 percent have it have had it in one at least
once in their life?
Speaker 1: Is it is it a bad thing in the
sense of is it a condition that we that we
are we try to treat, I guess, is the question.
Speaker 4: Right, so if you have it just like
a regular person, you have it once or twice
in your life, and indeed it can be scary.
I mean, you wake up paralyzed, you think you
might think you're going to die, perhaps.
And then there's a ghost in your room because
typically you have you hallucinate during
these experiences.
And so that is terrifying and frightening,
but it's not pathological and so on in its
own right, right?
It's just, you know, scary and things like
that.
But if you have it chronically, it becomes
a Paris Omnia, you know, so it's a fearful
thing that keeps occurring in your life.
And our research suggests if you give this
too much meaning and you say this is a demon
chasing me, I'm being possessed and things
like that which can occur in certain cultures,
well, then potentially you could even lead
to things like anxiety and maybe even trauma
from just, you know, being overwhelmed by
these, this paralysis and having these, you
know, scary hallucinations.
Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about the
dream component of sleep.
There is so much literature going back so
long with different ideas about dream meaning
and dream interpretation.
There are one side is it's completely random.
There's no connection whatsoever between dreams
and what's happening in the real world for
you.
There is another side which is know that the
dreams are a direct response to things that
are taking place in someone's life, and there
can be sort of specific meaning assigned to
them.
Let's start with maybe some of the common
dream tropes that a lot of people report.
So like falling in a dream and waking up before
you hit the ground is a very common theme.
Teeth falling out can be another common one.
The idea that you're kind of running or walking,
but it's almost like you're in molasses, like
it's very, very difficult to move.
You know, there's these common themes that
a lot of people seem to experience.
So it seems like it would follow that there
must be some meaning to those, at least.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
There is.
There's a pattern, right?
So let's take them one by one.
So you mentioned the tooth falling out.
So that seems to be due to sort of the end.
So all of us, right?
And at a certain age, when are children have
teeth literally falling out of our mouth?
And imagine this must be very anxiety provoking.
So obviously you will lay down memories of
this fear and anxiety that will remain with
you for many people, the rest of their lives.
But they can really, you know, pin down like,
why do I have this dream?
Why am I terrified of my dreams falling out?
Well, there was a period in our life where
our teeth were loose and we're literally falling
out.
So yes, you lay down these memories and the
memory parts of your brain and then you will
dream about them off.
Another very common dream is like being late
for an exam, even though, I mean, you're 40,
50, 60, you're running your business.
You're dreaming about being late for an exam,
right?
So that's a common one.
Then you mentioned the thing where you're
trying to, you know, run, you know, you can't
get away.
What's going on there?
Well, it turns out you're at your dream during
REM sleep during this dream stage of sleep
have a has a certain physiology and a certain
neural pattern.
And one of these the signatures of this is
that your the motor part of the brain, sort
of this part of the brain that has to do with
movement is sort of is not fueled by the chemicals
it needs to move, OK?
And but the emotional part of the brain is
hyperactive.
That's a chemical called as either choline
and the emotional parts of the brain are overactive.
So you have this clash between your motor,
part of the brain, the movement, part of the
brain being weakened and then the emotional
part of the brain instinctual, part of the
brain being overactive.
And that manifests as this you this dream
where you are running.
But you are really slow, right?
You're in quicksand and then this monster
is chasing you.
So that is an example of that.
And what you mentioned, the other one,
Speaker 1: the falling one, just falling and
waking up, you know, before
Speaker 4: you wake up.
I think that's unclear, but probably because
we used to dream in your sleep in high places,
right, like trees and things like that.
So it makes sense to have a reflex of, you
know, being able to catch yourself before
you fall.
So perhaps your brain has remnants of this
in its, you know, memory centers.
But you know, in short, your brain has a certain
chemistry during the dream stage, right?
So I ignore adrenaline.
This chemical that allows us to focus in on
being really focused is absent during the
dream stage, and that means things are like
space.
You can't really focus on a specific thing,
but it's more like the world is bizarre and
time is this and places are all warped.
So that's a signature of that, you know?
Or for example, there's no logic or a coherent
story, and that's because the logical part
of the brain is not working.
So there is this neural signature that defines
what you then see, but then you have memories
and things like that which you will sort of
pull in and sort of color the dream.
So if you live in a certain way, you will
dream about monsters relevant to your culture.
So you have all these elements, in fact, even
your environment, if you're in a cold room,
you might your dream of being in Iceland and
you know you know how you're having a fight
with.
Ice beer or something, you know, like with
a.
So so certainly environment, your physiology
and all that influences your dream in that
way.
Speaker 1: There are so many academic texts
and research now about sleep problems and
sleep problems are so common, particularly
in western countries, for sure.
And there's so many different aspects to this.
There's the hypnotic type medications like
Ambien and Lunesta that some people take.
There's the sleep hygiene aspect of you've
got to, you know, get off screens at least
an hour before going to bed.
Don't be doing things in your bedroom.
Other than sleeping.
Associate the bedroom with sleep.
You know all of the turn lights down.
There's kind of that aspect of it.
There's the more kind of like natural cures
type side, which often involves herbs or supplements
or apple cider vinegar and kind of all these
different things.
All of this different stuff, clearly because
we recognize that sleep is important and we
do better when when we've slept well, is there
some kind of overarching takeaways right now
that you think are the most important when
it comes to getting good sleep?
Speaker 4: Is it good?
It's a good question.
So I would say sleep at the same time and
wake up at the same time every day.
Your brain has this biological clock that
really defines when you feel tired and how
you get quality sleep.
So that's one thing.
The light issue is a huge thing.
Avoid bright light late in the night.
I mean, we know this, but it's very important
to, you know, stick to this.
You know, those are important to remember.
Stress and anxiety is the key one.
I mean, if you have stress and anxiety during
the day, your brain just can't turn off.
You know, the emotional parts of the brain
will be overactive and that will spill over
into the sleep state, you know, to sleep and
will just not allow you to have deep quality
sleep.
So those are the main thing.
So light exercise is so easy.
Just exercising, especially.
You can even do things like walking, you know,
that will help you get more deep sleep the
stage for before REM sleep.
That that's important sort of for, you know,
growth and just cellular repair and stuff
like that.
So exercise is a great one.
You know, I would say those are the main pillars.
And also, if you can sleep consistently, I
mean, we did some, there's some, but we did
not.
But there's some studies were done over in
Boston, David, where they showed that if you
sleep a regular amount of hours each night,
let's say even six or seven, that's better
than sleeping like eight, nine and then six
and five and then eight and 10.
And so having a regular, you know, amount
of sleep each night is better than just, you
know, going crazy and, you know, in the weekends
with like 12 hours.
Speaker 1: There are some people, I mean,
famously, Donald Trump, who says that for
his whole life, he's basically only slept
about four hours a night and that that's enough
that he feels fine.
I know, including from Matthew Walker's research,
that there is a range of what is sort of like
the natural correct amount of sleep for people.
But I've not seen anything empirical that
suggests that the human body can function
properly with an extended period of four hours
a night of sleep.
Can you talk about that at all?
Are there people who genuinely are fine with
that amount of sleep?
Speaker 4: You know, I was surprised when
I learned there actually is.
So there's a genetic genetic mutation in a
rare subset of people.
So it's very rare.
It's probably not.
You and I David Pakman OK, it's not me, but
there is a rare breed of people that can sleep
four or five hours.
So, you know, and they will feel rested and
they just sleep more efficiently.
They have this mutation.
And perhaps, you know, in a, you know, enough
time we'll all have this mutation if it's
if it's, you know, advantageous.
But certainly there is seems to be this genetic
mutation of people who sleep very little.
But I was quite surprised when I learned that
this seems to be the case, and there are some
folks in California doing research on this
very curious topic.
Yes, but but it is seems to be true.
Speaker 1: Have you studied a lot or read
a lot about the idea of the biphasic sleep
schedule?
There's this idea that back when we had to
stoke fires in the middle of the night, humans
would, you know, sleep three or four hours,
be up for an hour or two and then sleep another
three or four hours.
And it seems to be the sort of source of a
lot of debate because on the one hand, it
does appear as though there was a point at
which it would have made sense based on circumstances.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
a good or healthy thing to be doing right.
Speaker 4: I think the research on this is
emerging.
It could be that biphasic sleep in the way
you mentioned.
I mean, certainly people used to, many people
used to sleep like that, you know, with their
rituals at night and then going back to sleep.
And it seems like it could potentially be
good that you get more efficient sleep in
that way.
But the research, I would say, is emerging.
Another, you know, just element to this is
that also the whole idea of a siesta time
and sleeping.
During that time, and it seems also there
might be a biological advantage of doing that,
the fact that you will feel tired by noon
and sleeping for those hours could potentially
help and even napping can be very, very refreshing.
And, you know, sometimes you can compensate
for hours of sleep.
But I think the research on that, at least
from my knowledge, is 100 percent clear and
certainly not with the biphasic sleep.
But I wouldn't I wouldn't rule it out.
It could be that it's it's you get more, you
know, for your bang, for the buck.
By sleeping that way could be when
Speaker 1: you've talked about kind of like
the natural sleep schedules of people, there's
quite a bit of research that throughout our
lives, the natural wakefulness and sleepiness
schedule kind of shifts.
And one of the big areas of controversy with
this is the time that school starts for different
kids.
And when I was in high school, the first class
started at 7:35 a.m., which was completely
counter to my natural schedule, which was
to be up until 12:30 or 1:00 in the morning.
Now I get up far earlier.
That's a schedule that now now would work
much better for me.
Is there something to this idea that much
school is starting way too early?
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
So there is a genetic component to when you
want to fall asleep, you know, like there's
a chronotype in terms of like we have our
genetic preference in terms of when we want
to sleep and want to, you know, whether you
want to be night owls or not.
And so yes, for a lot of people, they will
just naturally be night owls.
They will be inclined to sleep very late and
wake up later.
And so for those folks, it's it's a problem
because you're starting school that early,
you will exclude these people.
In that way, you won't have their full, you
know, brain capacity, you know, using that.
So.
So it is something, but I'll say something.
You know, in my entire life, David, I was
I was sleeping maybe at 2:00 or 3:00 a.m.
That's just my natural thing.
But the last four years I've been sleeping
at 10 p.m., you know, so I've totally shifted
how I sleep as well, and it just works better.
So sometimes, even though you think you're
a night owl by nature, you might in fact be
somebody who is not so.
Speaker 1: No, me too.
I mean, I try.
I also saw this natural shift where because
of my schedule 10 15 and I was just getting
into bed and I thought to myself, I used to
kind of be a night owl.
Let me see what happens if I try to just stay
up a little later and get up a little later.
It felt very unnatural where I was.
Just find it.
It was, you know, 11:00.
And I was just like, I should just be in bed
right now.
This doesn't feel like it's my schedule any
longer.
Speaker 4: One hundred percent, that's what
happened to me, and I was surprised and I
was I thought I was genetically just doomed
to be somebody who has, you know, sleep at
three a.m.
But yeah, you know, I sleep much earlier and
I feel better.
Speaker 1: The work in the field is fascinating.
We've been speaking with Dr. Bulan Jalal,
who's a researcher at Harvard University and
also a visiting researcher at Cambridge University.
Really a pleasure having you on, and I appreciate
your time today.
Speaker 4: My pleasure, David.